great well thanks very much for the
opportunity to be here it's a great
pleasure and thanks to Shanti OMA and
Supan and Catherine DeRose for the
opportunity to speak I received one of
the most compelling invitations I've had
my in my academic career which was a
five-minute provocation which I thought
was beautiful and so here you have I
could have spoken about various aspects
of my research at the limits or
interdisciplinarity in various ways but
I chose to speak it to this audience
about something that's been occurring to
me which are perhaps underappreciated
unappreciated unspoken commonalities
between trends across the university
across academia between close and
distant readings in in science and
humanities of course close reading
doesn't really really need a definition
close reading is reading the reading we
all grew up with and and but I want to
just point out that when we're doing
reading we're reading in a stream of
time from a single object from a single
text from a single stimulus that there
is a bandwidth input output that can
limit this process right and that makes
it characteristic and gives it frankly
it's magic but as many of you know the
humanities have been and this intimate
connection to reading have been
challenged by other kinds of more modern
methods of analysis this for example is
a work of Franco Moretti a map of the
conversational interactions among
characters in Hamlet and
although though is not it's entirely
independent it's a distinct way of
taking in information and acquiring it
that that doesn't restrict itself to the
bandwidth of close reading right and
this kind of scholarship of course is
something that's made possible by by
digitization digital humanities and
alternative methods of analysis
unrealized within to too many of the
humanities might be a similar challenge
going on between traditional close
reading in the sciences and and
revolutions with scientists this is two
illustrations of cell signaling pathways
of sonic hedgehog on the left and bone
morphogenic protein on the right these
are based on literally thousands of
experimental papers done on model
organisms and development so up on the
upper left you see
ssshh is that's that's our little player
here sonic it binds to patched one which
inhibits smoothened and causing a
cascade of glee interactions toward the
left three enters the enters the nucleus
and and binds to the DNA
up-regulating or down regulating genes
and these kinds of knowledge are based
on thousands of experiments right by
thousands of people right at different
places in time this is an incredibly
complicated document lots and lots of
tissue
I'm going to compare that that
experimental knowledge or that method of
experiment to one that doesn't admit
doesn't restrict itself to the band's
same bandwidth this is a data set
acquired in my own lab by Jake musser
for his dissertation and it's comparing
genes within within development of
tissues in this case feathers and scales
and when choosing the fact that feathers
are a novelty they evolved in some
complicated way from scales which in the
relation between them so this expresses
a Venn diagram of thousands of genes
that are transcribed differently in
seven
issues from scale and where they are so
we have a circle for early epidermis and
late epidermis and late dermis and early
dermis of bird feathers right and you
see that there are thousands in some
cases hundreds in each little cell but
hiding up to a thousand this is an
entire scoop of tissue being analyzed at
once now we can also broaden the
bandwidth by asking the things about
different species so here we have
comparisons of alligators crocodiles and
and and various feathers and scales a
really complicated diagram with a
thousand little horizontal lines in each
row and what that shows is basically
that during the evolution of of chicken
scales and EMU scales and emu feathers
and chicken feathers from the ancestral
arc asourian alligator scale it turns
out that a legate the current feathers
are a lot more similar in their gene
expression to - alligator scales so
alligator scales of the left-hand column
are the right-hand column
feathers in the middle and you can see
there are many more light colored cells
on the left two-thirds and on the right
these are the practicum experiences that
come with asking questions in an
entirely different way for when I just
mentioned that these different
approaches of science what I will
analogize the close and distant readings
are shared across the discipline close
readings of all focus observations often
controlled analysis of singular
individualized objects at one place in
time intellectual connections are
incremental often building over
lifetimes or with armies of workers
distant reading involves broad
observations of Atlanta analysis of
large collections of object inferences
about difference arise as a result
distant readings are revolutionising the
science is in parallel with the
humanities and many challenges to
digital humanities are shared across the
academia for example on West Campus we
have a new systems biology Institute
which is an institute of distant reading
within biology at the inauguration of
the of the
the event Dean of the Graduate School
Tom Pollard came and gave introduction
usually these kinds of things are we'd
like to thank all the people that came
here etcetera etcetera there's coffee
outside thank you to our speakers
instead Pollard gave a blistering
critique of systems biology he's a close
reader and and and could not prevent
himself from raising the challenge so to
those of you who are in the digital
humanities who have seen blowback or
difference between your work and other
parts of the traditional academia this
is happening as well in the sciences and
I think it's something that could could
raise a new new dimension to how we
appreciate the role of computers the
role of Technology the role digitisation
and bandwidth in our analyses thanks
very much I am Jonathan Schroeder I'm a
postdoctoral associate in the D H lab
I'd like to invite our second speaker on
a diary's nya Rouge Nia up to the stage
she's coming from the department of
music and today she will be speaking
giving a talk entitled representing folk
well beyond digitization okay um this is
fine actually because it makes my point
for me my point is that in the digital
domain we lose track of the physical the
physical size of objects the physical
proportions of objects when I was a
junior in undergrad I was an Oxford for
the year and I was doing a tutorial that
was the tutorial of music history
because that's I was doing a music major
and in an Oxford tutorial he gets a sort
of one on one progression through
history we were in the early 14th
century that's as far as we've gotten
and I was given a call number for a book
to take out of the library um as a book
that looks something like that
why didn't have if everything is getting
stretched here um and I opened the book
I was handed to me and turned out to be
a book about a horse named Koval whose
name is an acronym for a whole bunch of
vices flattery
avarice villainy changefulness envy and
laziness and the story of favela by the
way is a yellow haired horse
hence the colorful from him is that he
despite all his vile qualities is
getting petted by everybody both
temporal and to me lait and clerical
authorities are petting him and he rises
so high that he decides he wants to try
to marry the goddess fortune fortune
won't happen and she gives him to
vainglory he marries vainglory there's a
big party there's a tournament between
the vices and the virtues the virtues
win but in the meantime Covell and his
progeny are baptized in a fountain of
[ __ ] and repair and here the book of the
book ends of the prayer that God
intervene else the garden of France will
be polluted by Favell and his level on D
in my thought was basically home what is
what is about the early 14th century
that makes them want to make a
manuscript about this and with music now
the way I interacted with that
manuscript then was very different from
the way that my students and I interact
with it now
the way you interact with it now is
through the digital portal of the
bibliothèque nationale de saucé and here
it is floating between sets of arrows
which is how manuscripts and PDFs and
all sorts of things float for us right
the image of a page just there on our
screen is still common that we don't
think about it but here I am with a copy
of the book that I was handed in Oxford
okay
the thing that impressed me most about
it was just how huge it is the biggest
look at ever been handed and so my
question about how would they make a
manuscript why would they make a
manuscript about this was a question
about resources that is this is a
one-to-one this is how big use
manuscript actually is I haven't seen it
in the flesh literally it's a parchment
manuscript and it's an impressive object
and of course that kind of thing it gets
lost these days now obviously things are
changed - I can now look up oval in
color anytime I want which I couldn't do
five years ago without going to Paris
and they wouldn't give it to me anyway
half the time that something is clearly
lost and among the many things that are
lost
I'll just signal the issue of the page
versus the opening as a unit of a
direction okay this is something that
medievalists know about and if you think
about when you're opening a book you're
actually looking at two different pages
and in the case of the hold on disposal
in this particular copy that becomes
very important because music is notated
across the opening so what you're seeing
here is different voices for a song so
here the first voice starts here and
goes there
the second voice starts here sorry fur
starts here and goes there and then this
is the third voice unless you're looking
at both pages you can't even sing it but
of course energy sing it you have to
know something about early 14th century
music notation in order to refill Val
you have to know something about
medieval French and medieval Latin and
in order to understand its pictures you
have to be an art historian the person
who is ready to understand this object
without mediation doesn't exist now and
probably didn't in the early 14th
century because it was a collaborative
effort so just to give you a sense for
how we scholars interact with these
things now here is a slide that works
really well when PowerPoint is working
and basically what it tells you is that
this piece is edited in more publication
this piece and another the text is
edited in another thing and this little
tiny piece of chant is edited
a third place we have discriminated this
object in order to make sense of it and
so one of the ways the digital domain
can help is to to kind of put it back
together but is there a way to put it
back together that still respects its
physical dimensions which is so
important to the process of
understanding and using it ok so this
story began in Oxford a long time ago a
continued five or so years ago at
Princeton where I was teaching and I
went to my colleague Rebecca Sebring who
was also teaching at Princeton at the
time she's now on both lists in London
and she is an HDI person in music so she
works on making novel musical
instruments novel ways of for musicians
to interact with with sound generating a
software and to create new sounds she's
also the author of Weka Nader and I
don't know if that's a code that's
familiar to anybody but it's a way to
turn almost anything into a musical
instrument one of her students that turn
their pet snake into a musical
instrument I'm sushi when when I went to
her I brought the book and I said look
at this how can we make this digital
without losing its bringing that and we
decided to use a large multi of
multi-touch tabletop computer where we
could have swivel app size now five or
seven years ago we paid like twelve
thousand dollars for something that no
longer works in any ways at Princeton
and we are both no longer there but the
gh lab has gotten us a much nicer bigger
surface so we're in the process of
reprogramming now what does our software
do or have done will do again once we
get it back up and running all it allows
us to look at the manuscript at size and
also to have various kind of controls to
mediate our experience with it the
simplest but probably most effective
thing we've done is to map out each
folio in an XML file the basically says
this is a voice of a motet this is lines
X through Z of the poem this is an image
and what that allows us to do is
actually then use different XML files to
say can you show it to me in English
obviously a really important thing if I
want to teach with it so here you can
see or would be able to see this is
actually overlay text right you can
that's no longer handwriting and you can
say I want to see an old French I want
to see it in English so now we can look
at full Bell with a translation floating
above while still understanding where it
sits on the page because that is
important because all sorts of
multimedia connections are being made in
this source Clavell is a very early very
important multimedia object and here you
can see a close-up of English text
floating in a semi-transparent box above
a summative version of the page we can
still zoom and then there's an image
next to it so you can start to see how
this works in multimedia we also can
look at editions of the music right next
to the music itself we can do search on
images and text I'm sorry so basically
we're trying to think more broadly about
house and we preserve some of the most
important things that tend to get erased
in the process of users digitization
right and insofar as this generation so
often seems to be the end of some v:h
endeavors how can we move beyond it in a
way that actually respects the
physicality and the particularity of the
objects that were digitizing we wouldn't
be the first people to gather around a
book and talk about it and think about
it together thank you
[Applause]
next we have on yet alhasan who's the
associate curator at the yale babylonian
collection and also she's a lecturer and
the Department of Near Eastern languages
and civilizations it's working all right
so um yeah I'm from the Babylonian
collection and I want to talk about some
difference digitization initiatives
we've had their first I actually want to
not talk about three initiatives because
I only have five minutes so I don't have
time to mention all of them the first
project we did with the imaging lab out
at bar PCH and there's a video that the
Yale News created that you can find on
YouTube and look it up and this is the
final result it's a model of a tablet
that's almost 4,000 years old that you
spin it out and we're sharing it with
teachers and museums across the world so
that they can print out their own models
of the Pythagorean tablet the next thing
that I'm not going to talk about is 3d
printing and I think summer already
talked about this so she mentioned
there's a little display just outside
and you can see print out for you
pendants in plastic of two pieces of
destroyed architecture from Palmyra that
piece there is the arc of triumph it was
unveiled at Chicago Square in London
it's not actual size it's some 60% of
the real thing and the pieces that we
have out there just around this ayah so
you really you're not getting the full
picture of what this architecture was
but it is a type of from per serving is
something that's destroyed so the other
thing about this is
these pieces came from Syria and they
were erected this was erected in London
and a lot of the key reasons I had felt
that this was of course nice there was a
global interest in their material their
cultural heritage the key we didn't
appreciate their cultural heritage so
close to the British Museum where they
you know many of their pieces suicide
today and the first thing I'm not going
to talk about is Babylonian cookbooks
and augmented reality it's an it's a
display in the availab Museum in
Rotterdam that's on right now so we have
three three thousand eight hundred years
old cookbooks in the Babylonian
collection and they're too fragile to
travel so we had them TV models and they
were printed in the Netherlands and what
you see here is sort of a data mapping
so they're recipes and what you see to
the left this is the ingredients you see
them at the bottom that would go into
the recipe there and then you hear a
voice who's speaking the recipe in
Acadian and over there you see sort of
data mapped on top of the Acadian you
see the the transliteration of the
occasion alright so and what I am going
to talk about is um two other projects
that we where we had ongoing in the
Babylonian collection so this
illustration here is from an article
from last year in the New York Times
it's about a project to use big data or
data mining searches to ancient texts to
find out if the laws that govern our
economy if they apply to ancient economy
as well or if there is a fundamental
difference between the capitalist
economy and that of the ancient world
and the illustration that you see here
there is sort of very you know Indiana
Jones for standing and phantoms of ruins
and he's looking at some algorithms but
if you look at the work that they're
doing there's not a lot of Indiana Jones
about it it's all algorithms and
statistics and visualizations of data so
in a ray I system feels that you get a
little removed together for your point
is that removed from the objects that
you are studying or the the people that
you are working with of this sort has a
historian so I work with still in the
fields and some of the fields are there
about you know one inch tall not more
than that and they functions in ancient
Mesopotamia as signatures and you roll
them out on your document that you write
on clay and here you see impressed in
the sculpey elephant Grayskull P which
is what we use in the Babylonian
collection the images that were carved
on this tiny little cylinder I want to
focus on just one steel and this is what
the original publication of that field
look like so it's a it's a rollout of
the object and it was presented in black
and white in 1934 yeah
and it was republished in 1996 with I
think even less um
data you see the barest trying no color
not even the the QA from text I was
parked into the surface of the steel
here you see an image of the seal and is
roll out to see the sort of you lose
some information in this way of
publishing your seals so this is a
visualization of the same seal and it
was created by Rev learning collections
imaging specialist Klaus Magnus Anna who
is right there and I am working on a
research project to
think about how the ancient craftsperson
interacted with this stone with the
material and how this choices of
placement of images and texts played in
with the stones that that the the
patterning of this stone of the object
and if we just go back to this you see
this is not something that I can use in
my research at all whereas this is very
useful on visualization technique I want
to show you another seal and here you
see the imagery of the roll out of it
and here you see an HDR image of the
seal and I'm going to show this to you
because to be your the visualization the
image almost becomes an artwork in
itself so it's starting just like an
research object but it becomes an
artwork that you can appreciate just for
the for the beauty of it alright so the
other project that I want to highlight
is teaching a virtual reality and I hope
that you will all go out and try the
headset at the poster presentation after
this to visit the throne room in an
Assyrian Palace from the ninth century
BCE so as the summer also show you know
this is one of these places that was
bombed by Isis and they took great care
and really destroying every single
relief that was originally in this
palace but actually a lot of portraits
also the images that you saw from from
Nineveh that you showed before that was
a reconstruction that wasn't the
original that wasn't is the dumb era
reconstruction of the architecture most
of the numeral palace was dismantled in
the mid-1800s by European power
who came in and here's part of the of
the relief right here we have including
this cat seven pieces from the from from
the Palestinian root and here you see
where Justin but just one of the rooms
is spread across the three continents so
a team has been working since the 80s on
finding out where are these pieces of
reliefs in the world and then
reassembling and it's one program into
one model okay to reassembling it into
one model and we have here at Yale this
virtual reality model where you can
yourself go into this virtual space and
look at the relief as they were before
the palace was torn about to an apart in
the in the 19th century and see how they
appear in their original settings you
can go to the art gallery and P 2 of
these reliefs on display and observe
what they look like in a museum setting
completely removed from any of their
original context but how they they are
understood in a museum space and then
you can visit this virtual reality model
after Richmond see how they were how
they form part of a very large and
expensive narrative image program that
was designed and thought up and the 9th
century BC alright so I hope you go and
try that virtual reality model thank you
[Applause]
is my pleasure to introduce our next
speaker
peter leonard the director of the
digital humanities lab his talk today is
titled machine vision in the archive
neural networks and visual similarity
thanks very much John so what I'm going
to show you guys today is a kind of
response to a provocation that was given
to me by actually Amy Hungerford some
other folks at Yale who work in the
space of or who are interested in the
problem of what we might call visual
culture computation so what I mean by
visual culture computation well my own
background is in text mining so my own
experience is dealing with Unicode text
but here at Yale we have an amazing
amount of information in our museums in
our art galleries in our special
collections and the by Nikki and hasard
special collections all over campus in
the Ballou nyan collection which will
never be reducible down to text they are
always going to exist in visual or the
Victorian realm and so one of the
questions we've been asking ourselves at
Yale is are there any interesting data
mining techniques any interesting
machine learning techniques that might
help us get affordances get a handle on
to the amazing amount of culture held at
Yale individual domain and so what I
want to do today is talk very quickly
just about of an demonstration interface
the interface we've built is on top of a
collection of 19th century photography
which was recently acquired by the
Beinecke Rare Book and Manuscript
library on that collection is in the
process of being digitized at a very
high quality level what we show you
today is just about 27,000 images at a
very small quality level but I think I
can make a point with so what I want to
do is before I show you these images
I'll bring up the website right now but
what I want to do first is just talk
about what we're interested in doing so
obviously when we have a whole bunch of
images let's just say perhaps for this
argument's sake about 27,000 images from
the 19th century what we could do is we
could build an interface that has a back
button and a next button and you would
hit that back button and you only have
to hit it about 2 to 20 6999 times until
you reach the end of the
archives and that will work really well
your finger might get tired the other
thing you might be able to do is you
might be able to search for words like
boxer or opera singer or stereogram or
something like that and if the metadata
that we have or if the metadata that we
create through our cataloging team is
good enough then you'll be able to find
all the pictures of boxers or all the
pictures of Confederate generals but the
problem would be what happens if we
aren't sure that our metadata will ever
be fully descriptive of what's on the
screen here so every time I'm reloading
I'm just showing you a couple different
samples from a twenty-seven thousand
strong image collection from the 1862
1890s we could hope that somebody's
going to label this guy you know
half-naked boxer but actually maybe have
a label a huge list because that's
actually what would have been called
back then so the problem is how am I
going to be able to find all of these
images in the archive an instead of
searching or instead of hitting the back
button in the next button twenty-six
thousand 999 times what would be really
exciting to us as if we were just able
to move our mouse over a particular
image and have all images that are
visually similar to this image appear so
this would be true not only of this guy
but also of that guy and this guy and
this guy sitting at an angle maybe even
Bridges would come up simply reload
these a couple more if we're interested
in women with really ornate hairstyles
we're interested in intense men with
beards women and wives going off in the
distance nature so how are we doing this
every time I'm moving my mouse over the
image what we're basically doing is
asking for the visually photos in this
collection which are the most visually
similar to the image that we're looking
at here and the way we're getting this
metric of visual similarity is we're
actually using an artificial neural
network we're using a pre-trained of
neural network that is designed for a
modern problem which is captioning
pictures that you take with your
smartphone but behind the scenes what we
can do is use this neural network as a
kind of artificial vision a high
dimensional representation of thousands
upon thousands of different ways of
seeing it's not too important for us to
understand how the neural network works
because the internals of it are somewhat
opaque even to computer scientists what
is important for us to
stand is that the neural network sees in
about 2048 dimensions what we can then
do is ask an algorithm to find the
approximate nearest neighbors of all the
27,000 pictures in this 2048 dimensional
space that's a lot of maps for a human
it's not a lot of math for a algorithm
so what we can do is basically say in
this 2048 dimensional space what are the
pictures which are nearest to this
picture of Teresa liebe or what are the
pictures that are nearest to this
gentleman right here there's another
thing we can do we can take this 2048
dimensional space that captures about
2048 different ways of seeing what we
can do is use a dimensionality reduction
on this high dimensional space because
it's very difficult for us to draw or
visualize anything in more than two
dimensions here we have 2048 but we can
collapse those dimensions using a sort
of a dimensionality reduction in this
case it's Disney and what this will do
is it'll allow us to visualize all these
pictures in on a screen which only has
X&Y so let me show you what a
dimensionality reduction of a 2048
dimensional space looks like with some
of the images from this 19th century
collection over here you can see that a
lot of our stereograms are in the lower
left hand corner because they share
certain visual characteristics they're
doubled they often have a yellow or a
red frame over here I think they're
actually some portraits of Native
Americans who are all clustered in the
same two-dimensional space and then
intriguingly for those students of the
19th century the battlefield dead at
Antietam are clustered over here because
they share the same characteristics
really of many blades of grass and
bodies aligned horizontally what's
interesting about this visualization is
that it's space is globally meaningless
but locally meaningful there's no
significance to the fact the the
Antietam pictures show up on the top in
the middle left and the stereogram show
up on the bottom but what is meaningful
or the local arrangements of images so
here we have a whole bunch of Second
Empire buildings taken at 45 degree
angles probably in New York City over
here you have various other images that
also here here's probably images of the
same building that are taken and so what
we're asking us to do is to think about
this two-dimensional space as an
arbitrary but still
diagnostically meaningful a compression
or reduction of this high dimensional
visual space and this technique together
with this other technique here can be I
think a useful way of making sense of a
collection which is eventually going to
grow to 80,000 images
saving all of our mouse buttons the task
of hitting that button to the next image
80,000 times
thanks for English our last panelist is
Larry Weiland who's a senior research
scientist in the School of Engineering
and Applied Science and it's my mentor
at the Yale Center for engineering
innovation and design his talk of titled
examples of speak of steam in the seed
mathematics of soap bubbles physics is
chocolate and the artful engineering of
music thank you so in the Center for
engineering innovation and design we
have lectures and workshops that are
specifically designed to sort of bring
together people and sort of topics from
different areas combining very you know
very intentionally science technology
engineering mathematics with the arts
and what I'm going to do is just sort of
show you some examples and highlight
some of the student work that I think
kind of speaks for itself and showing
how by bringing these together you know
it provides an incredibly enriching
experience along the way I'll kind of
also mention various digital techniques
that that are used throughout in what I
would say are somewhat unique ways I've
actually brought a bunch of some sort of
demonstrations I may not have time to
show all of them to you but I can have
some of them available later on if
people want to come up and look at them
so I'm just going to start off with a
video one of the students
hopefully this will work
Oh
[Music]
so this was just an excerpt from our
final presentations and I mean of course
that I teach with Conrad of Merak from
the Department of Music the course is
called music acoustics and instrument
design and in this course we teach the
students initially a lot about the
acoustics of music and you know waves on
strings waves and solids all sort of
math and physics in high patristic
instruments and then Conrad kind of
takes over and talks about digital music
and digital music synthesis techniques
and in the last part of the course of
students get to build whatever kind of
concern they can conceive of I think the
interesting thing here was it has been
caught it and it went by pretty fast but
Jordan think was an American Studies
major but in the summers who goes to LA
and directed for television and movie
successfully as far as I understand so
you know he came from a completely
different background we got thrown into
this course where we were to see him
about all the physics and engineering of
getting to the engineering tools like
tab and really printing and laser
cutting you know all these tools to
build things and then we sort of set
them loose so I'm just going to point
out some the interesting I can later
maybe show a video and playing this
instrument but I'll bring up my
powerpoint
so this instrument was essentially an
organ constructed of and uh oh I don't
think I see all of my pictures here so
but I can because I
so Jordan kinda figure out how to play
notes drop bottle you want to create an
instrument instrument out yes the
quality process the picture I add is him
holding the bottle and producing the
delicate taking selfies of themselves
and then it turns out I am bliss which
has a high curve and then he in order to
get the notes I drop Wow the stream of
air does not actually at home series
each of that shape and an impact you
know made around 82 so by doing that
could produce something that would make
the right sound is we instructed a whole
instrument out of that with some salt
where he could play in a direct the air
across different bottles so that was
just an example of using some digital
techniques combining them with this
musical background but using all the
engineering and science essence it
Yvonne
so I only in fact don't do that when
pictures here but I have
I was the convention so cold as
something that I didn't compare show
afterwards interested in xt-1 sorta how
to sort of thing to be talking about
what we do a workshop on soap bubbles
where we used to IRS's of those who saw
mathematical so you solve business
problems even so I happen to hear my
rocket words that I will work so I'm
just a little later let us just kind of
bring out in my drawers and drive
so this is musical instrument that
their combination later body and married
digital strays reduced mobility along
and Gordie Howe lower motor turn
motocross on volume and then push those
up there is above the strain
my father he had a way to change the
pacification black-budget also disguise
alert along the straight so you can play
a gentleman and
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and
[Music]
culture being back and the demos later
on occasion classification logistics by
a vertical and clap he eventually ended
up making an ood so you'll see him
playing this instrument and it was built
except for the tuning pegs completely
built in the CID using a lot of digital
tools such as you know computer and Eric
American control milling machine and
laser cutting etc
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
so that's pretty incredible
you came in just made that three weeks I
would say and you can only make an
instrument like that in such a short
time if you take take advantage of all
the digital tools that we have to offer
northern living with that moving
handcrafted it might be a better
instrument and of metal but by using
these tools you can make something that
you designed in your head very quickly
place it extremely well I don't know
what my time is like but I could show
one more demonstration if I have another
yeah so I'll let us finish up with one
more handle
but this was a sort of an interesting
one a student dated tourists came into
the class as a computing Vader and based
on audio torment and for maneuvers that
produce
also their beautiful provincial masters
and filters in hand
after thinking about respond certainly
going from vishal back catalogue but it
is still a bunch of filters that anyone
using 3d technology that essentially
produces Oklahomans and the district in
certain at all nutrients and visual
science or world
problem yes I think I'm done
thank you everyone for your talk I'm
just going to quickly introduce you
again as if anyone came in late
we have onion alhasan as Peter Leonard
Anna as IRAs nya um we have Richard prom
and we have Larry Weiland and then the
first question I would like to ask is
how did you venture outside of your
field to work in the intersection of
Arts and Sciences alright so I think
that the dumb the visualization the the
images of the seals that Klaus so kindly
produce I think that was it was not in
an intentional effort but it was just
seeing those images sees the aesthetic
septum was word
I don't know so powerful to me that I
chose and I were talking about doing an
exhibition just with these just with the
images without any sort of foam just
letting the images speak for themselves
I guess for myself my undergraduate
degree is in art history and my
doctorate is in European literature but
I feel like there's so much cultural
heritage material being digitized
nowadays by institutions such as Yale
and by in for-profit corporations such
as Google that there's a kind of moral
imperative to apply the data mining and
machine learning that's coming out of
places like Silicon Valley in order to
ensure that humanists remain in charge
of the manipulation and the
comprehension of all this material
I don't really feel that I've ventured
in the sense that I'm collaborating but
also that the multimedia is not you know
the domain of the sciences exclusively
so I think that as young I'm a literate
user of Technology or whatever the
whatever the word with the adjective
would be as a competent user and so I am
thinking about you're just what are the
various timely tools at my disposal to
answer the questions that I'm answering
from really from within my discipline
but also thinking about pedagogy and
access
yeah wented a few slides that showed
that challenges of big data and
communicating about it in science and I
think they're parallel we have to invent
new tools and we're inventing new
graphical tools to communicate data but
one of the other challenges I'm doing in
my lab is to try to visualize what birds
look like to birds
we're all color blind with respect to
birds Percy
in the UV which is beyond blue but
because they have four color receptors
it's more than just beyond velu it's
actually an additional dimension to
color so they see all kinds of colors we
can imagine like ultraviolet yellow
which is a special kind of purple that
you know if it's different it is
different from yellow as purple is from
red and first use these in their daily
lives they are dense so it's a huge
digital challenge but also a
computational graphical challenge there
aren't cures for colorblindness so we
can't actually experience what birds see
but we can we can study the hell out of
it using these kind of new tools so in
visualization is a big part for me
really you know exercise what's that you
should use it so you should use it
is it on yeah for me you know sort of
venturing into this collaboration you
know came out of some of my natural
interest in music to begin with I had
already taught acoustics you know it's
sort of a physics course but really it
just came out of finding the perfect
kind of person to collaborate with so
can't give say enough about Conrad who I
work with and so it's just the right
combination of the kind of physics and
engineering that we you know we're
already doing the CID with the sort of
digital techniques that that he's an
expert in and so it came out of a
conversation and and you know I think
the great thing was is that we with no
hesitation whatsoever from either of the
departments we were given the go-ahead
to to start to you know move forward
with that class it's great
we'd like to open up questions the
audience
thank you very much all of you for your
talks were fascinating and very diverse
this is one I was very kind of touched
and humbled by how many of them touched
on pedagogy and on teaching and also
just interested in this question of
means versus ends with some digital
humanities projects leading to a product
that has been imported into the
classroom and some in some cases the
creation of the final platform that
process being a pedagogical moment as
well especially some of the toxins I
just want to throw that out there
something you've thought about and how
that supports itself out in all of your
projects if I may say something about
that so for us it's teaching is it's a
lot about recreating a context or
creating a space that we can't visit
either because we would never go to to a
place or because it's been it's been
destroyed or because our objects are
very fragile so we want to have that
teaching to things experience but we
don't want our objects to be destroyed
because of handling so using
digitization different types of
digitization techniques makes makes it
possible to use objects in the classroom
without compromising the actual objects
I think it's also a question of sharing
this you know you get it in a in a form
in a digitized form where you can share
it with your colleagues across the world
and also with the people who you know we
have a responsibility as a cultural
heritage institution in the Babylonian
collection that everything that we have
come from places where there's a lot of
destruction of cultural heritage and you
know we you know we you know
we want to provide them with access to
the objects and also with scholarly
tools that they might not have through
expensive books and you know we can't
even pay for their JSTOR you know so
France ups digitize residences is that's
an end for our digitization goal I mean
I think of course the answer to process
our product is yes right but um and so
with the digital clock Valley it was
originally programmed by student
undergraduate programmers because that
was the nature of the Grammy had from
Princeton and it was a really wonderful
experience because the programmers found
themselves asking really kind of
ontological questions about the nature
of materiality or encoding right you
wait the minute you have pieces of music
that have multiple voices what's the
best way to represent that object
digital use which is part of the same
thing should there be a sort of super or
admit things they belong to and pretty
quickly you're asking actually very
meaningful questions about what is the
nature of song right but I think that
it's very important as a researcher that
sort of in charge on one of these
projects to keep your own questions
there because it seems like sometimes
the building of the tools
ends up being the end in itself and I'm
trying to really keep my what are my
sort of most personal questions for this
manuscript to try to create a tool that
ultimately helps me answer them because
otherwise I think we lose interest
they're cuddly
you each represent a department can you
imagine
20 30 years from now will the
department's you're in be history and
would be organized creating a group of
studies that that would be differently
catalog are we in the middle of some
sort of earthquake change
i won i currently I'm in ecology and
evolutionary biology and I right now I
have collaborations in chemistry
economics you know mechanical and
chemical engineering Applied Physics all
around the University so I am in spread
out as you can get and but I really hope
that in 200 years there will be a
department with a certain mission in
ecology and evolutionary biology I'm
also a member of the department the
ornithology department division of the
peabody museum and part of the reason
why they hired me was because they have
150,000 birds in the collection that
institution and it's durability that
department and it lasts Ignace defined
in that way by the material objects the
verbs contributes to the discipline
itself so I love the interconnections
but the core missions are also essential
to the university I sincerely hope that
the music department still be here in 20
years I think it is linearity is
predicated on disciplinary I think we
all still need to be experts in
something so that our collaborations are
strong collaborations and if you imagine
say music and write I speak as somebody
who is a 30 14th century music right
that's deep deep humanity right but if
you take the music department out of it
or take people who study music primarily
out of it yes there'll be music in terms
of other departments but nobody will
have that commitment to music and things
will be lost already the notation I
study in terms of people who know how to
read it that
Vernors has gotten very small and we're
doing something to raise that literacy
back up because because not we need to
keep very sense of knowledge in play so
my answer is yes or no I camera how was
great I hope so yeah oh sorry I think we
might might be going too close here
because we're way out of time
I'd like to invite Susan given up to
deliver her closing remarks but please
everyone give a hand to all of the all
dependent today wonderful poster session
net so I don't I want to make sure I
give me the time for that I'll keep my
remarks very very short I hope you
experience today
what the title is of this conference
which is Beyond Boundaries and as we've
been talking about all afternoon the
what we heard about what we saw and how
the different disciplines can be working
together and this is disciplinary
boundaries while the disciplines are
still vitally important their
collaboration that's possible and what
we hope is a conference like this or
spending time in the digital humanities
lab which is here in
serling library provides you with that
opportunity to collaborate and realize
the methodologies that you can bring
from different disciplines together the
technology as well as the humanistic
questions that can be meshed together to
really explore different ideas so I hope
you'll follow up with us if you were
excited by some of the things you saw
today to visit us in the digital
humanities lab to participate in Yale
team the Center for teaching and
learning there's lots of ways where we
can carry on this
before we go I want to make sure that we
thank a couple people Kathy the Rose I
know put a tremendous effort into this
event today and so I wanted to have
around the clock I also want to say
thank you for putting up with this space
I know it's a challenging room and
starting next month it will be
completely renovated so if we have this
conference next year this will still be
electra hall but it will have
comfortable seating better acoustics and
different technology so hang in there
with us as we're going to make that and
then the last piece is that the
evolution of our early work here in the
discipline humanities lab that starting
this December will be engaging in a
renovation project of the Franklin
family periodical reading room and that
will become the future home of the D H
lab so a much larger space on the main
floor of the library and we hope to open
this up next summer that project is made
possible to the generosity of to the
white shadow foundation that has been
supporting the H labs activities of the
last three years and also Richard barber
Frankie's who are here with us today who
have also probably the first to say I'll
renovate booth renovate a room not once
but twice to make sure it's aligned for
purposes of this university so if you
join me in thanking
you
you
you
[Music]